Entonces, aquí, lo llamamos 1000 ciudades con una cara.
Como arquitecto en China,
tengo que preguntarme, ¿qué puedo hacer al respecto?
Un día, caminando por una calle
vi gente vendiendo pescado.
Y habían puesto los peces en esta pecera cúbica.
Entonces me hice la misma pregunta,
¿Por qué un espacio cúbico para peces?
¿Les gusta el espacio cúbico?
(Risas)
Obviamente no.
Entonces, tal vez el espacio cúbico, la arquitectura cúbica,
es más barata, es más fácil de hacer.
Entonces, hice esta pequeña investigación,
Instalé una cámara e intenté observar cómo se comportan los peces
en este espacio cúbico.
Y luego descubrí que probablemente no eran felices.
El espacio cúbico no era el hogar perfecto para ellos,
así que decidí diseñar una nueva pecera para ellos.
Creo que debería ser más orgánica,
Debería haber un espacio más fluido dentro.
Interiores más complejos.
Creo que deberían sentirse más felices viviendo en este espacio,
pero no lo sabré porque no me hablan.
(Risas)
Pero un año después
tuvimos la oportunidad de diseñar este edificio real para humanos.
Estas son en realidad un par de torres
que construimos en Mississauga, una ciudad a las afueras de Toronto.
La gente las llama las Torres Marilyn Monroe,
(Risas)
por sus curvas.
Y la idea era construir una torre,
Una torre residencial de gran altura, pero no una caja.
Está más inspirado por la naturaleza,
con la dinámica del sol y el viento.
Después de terminar de diseñar la primera torre,
nos dijeron,
"No tienes que diseñar la segunda,
solo repite el mismo diseño
y te pagamos el doble".
Pero dije: "No se pueden tener dos Marilyn Monroes de pie allí".
Y la naturaleza nunca se repite,
Así que ahora tenemos dos edificios que pueden bailar juntos.
Me tengo que hacer una pregunta.
Ya saben, ¿por qué, en la ciudad moderna,
a menudo pensamos que la arquitectura es una máquina, es una caja?
Aquí quiero ver cómo la gente miraba la naturaleza en el pasado.
Al mirar esta pintura tradicional china,
descubrí que a menudo se mezclaban
la naturaleza y lo artificial, hecho por el hombre, de manera dramática,
y crean este escenario emocional.
Entonces, en la ciudad moderna, mi pregunta es:
¿Hay alguna manera de no separar edificios y naturaleza,
sino de combinarlos?
Hay otro proyecto que construimos en China.
Es un complejo residencial bastante grande.
Y se encuentra en un entorno natural muy hermoso.
Para ser sincero, la primera vez que visité el sitio,
me resultó tan hermoso
que casi decidí rechazar el proyecto
porque me sentía como un criminal haciendo algo allí.
No quiero convertirme en un criminal.
Pero mi segundo pensamiento fue:
si no lo hiciera
ellos simplemente pondrían igualmente, allí torres urbanas estándar.
Y eso sería una pena.
Así que decidí que tenía que intentarlo.
Así que la forma en que lo hicimos fue
tomar las curvas de nivel de las montañas existentes,
y esas líneas luego las tradujimos a un edificio.
Esas torres están tomando formas
y geometrías de la naturaleza.
Cada edificio tiene una forma diferente,
un tamaño diferente, diferente altura.
Y se convierten en extensión de la naturaleza
donde están situados.
Y saben,
la gente piensa que usamos la computadora a veces
para diseñar este tipo de arquitectura,
pero en realidad hago muchos bocetos a mano,
porque me gusta la aleatoriedad en el boceto a mano.
Y pueden llevar emociones
y eso no puede hacerse con computadoras.
Arquitectura, humanos y naturaleza pueden coexistir juntos
y están teniendo una buena relación en esta foto.
En realidad, este chico de la foto es uno de los arquitectos de nuestro equipo.
Creo que ha estado disfrutando del hermoso paisaje natural,
y sintiéndose aliviado de que él no es parte de los criminales...
(Risas)
al final.
De vuelta a la ciudad,
en Beijing, nos pidieron diseñar unas torres urbanas.
E hice este modelo.
Es un modelo de arquitectura,
parece una minimontaña y minivalles.
Puse este modelo en mi mesa y lo regué todos los días.
Y años después, completamos este edificio.
Y pueden ver cómo mi dibujo a mano
es traducido al edificio real.
Se parecen bastante.
Parece una montaña negra.
Así es como este edificio está situado en la ciudad.
Está al borde de este hermoso parque.
Es diferente, muy diferente de los edificios circundantes,
porque otros edificios tratan de construir un muro alrededor de la naturaleza.
Pero lo que intentamos hacer aquí
es que el edificio sea parte de la naturaleza,
para que podamos extender la naturaleza del parque a la ciudad.
Esa fue la idea.
Un crítico de arte chino dibujó esta pintura.
Puso nuestro edificio en esta pintura.
¿Pueden ver que hay una pequeña montaña negra?
Se ve muy bien en esta pintura.
Sin embargo, en esta realidad,
nuestro diseño estaba siendo desafiado
por verse tan diferente a los de los alrededores.
Me pidieron que modificara mi diseño,
ya sea color o forma,
para hacer que el edificio se ajustara mejor al contexto.
Entonces mi pregunta fue:
¿por qué se ajusta a este contexto natural tradicional,
mejor que la realidad?
Tal vez hay algo equivocado con la realidad.
Algo está mal con el contexto.
En la parte más al norte de China,
también construimos esta casa de ópera.
Es una casa de ópera al lado del río,
en el parque de humedales.
Decidimos hacer de este edificio parte del paisaje circundante
y que se fundiera en el horizonte.
El edificio literalmente parece una montaña nevada.
La gente puede caminar sobre el edificio.
Durante el día o cuando no hay ópera,
la gente viene aquí, pueden disfrutar de las vistas,
y pueden continuar su viaje del parque
a dentro del edificio.
Cuando llegan a la azotea,
hay un anfiteatro que enmarca el cielo
donde pueden cantar al cielo.
Dentro de la ópera
tenemos este lobby con mucha luz natural,
y también pueden disfrutar de este espacio semi-interior-exterior,
y pueden ver la hermosa vista a su alrededor.
He estado construyendo varias montañas
y aquí estoy tratando de mostrar
un edificio que creo que parece una nube.
Es el Museo Lucas de Artes Narrativas
que se está construyendo en la ciudad de Los Ángeles.
Es un museo creado por George Lucas,
el creador de las películas de "Star Wars".
¿Por qué un edificio que se parece a una nube?
Porque creo, imagino, la nube es misteriosa.
Es la naturaleza.
Es surrealista cuando este elemento natural aterrizó en la ciudad.
Y te hace sentir curiosidad al respecto,
y quieres explorarlo
Así es como el edificio aterrizó en la tierra.
Al levantar este museo,
haciéndolo flotar sobre el suelo
Podemos liberar mucho paisaje y espacio debajo del edificio.
Y luego podemos, al mismo tiempo,
crear este jardín en la azotea sobre el edificio
que pueden visitar y disfrutar de la vista.
Este museo se completará en el año 2022,
y todos están invitados cuando se complete.
Después de construir todas estas montañas y nubes,
ahora estamos construyendo estos volcanes
de vuelta en China.
Este es en realidad un gran parque deportivo
con cuatro estadios adentro,
con un estadio de fútbol con 40 000 asientos.
Es un proyecto muy grande.
Y ven en esta foto que
difícilmente se puede saber dónde hay construcción y dónde hay paisaje.
El edificio se convierte en un paisaje.
Incluso se convierte en un "land art",
donde la gente puede caminar alrededor del edificio,
puede subir a este edificio
mientras deambulan en este parque de volcanes.
Esta representación muestra uno de los espacios en esos volcanes.
Esto es en realidad una piscina
con luz natural que viene de arriba.
Entonces, lo que estamos tratando de crear
en realidad es un entorno que desdibuja el límite
entre arquitectura y naturaleza.
Así la arquitectura ya no es una máquina funcional para vivir.
También refleja la naturaleza que nos rodea.
También refleja nuestra alma y espíritu.
Como arquitecto, no creo
que en el futuro deberíamos repetir esas cajas de fósforos sin alma nunca más.
Creo que lo que busco es la oportunidad
para crear un futuro
con armonía entre humanos y naturaleza.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)